Apple music is all of the ways you love
music all in one place and we're
launching in over a hundred countries
later this month
with iOS 8.4 for your iPhone iPod touch
and iPad as well as a new version of
iTunes for the Mac a new version of
iTunes for Windows and Android is coming
this fall hey the first time we go to
for you we want to find out a little bit
about your musical tastes and so we're
gonna ask you what genre as you like a
big fan of rock pop hip hop and
alternative and now it will ask me for
some of artists that I like I love Bruce
Springsteen so I'm gonna tap twice I
like Lorde like Alabama Shakes and now
we're going to take all of this
information you've provided along with
all of your playlists and the songs that
you purchased on iTunes and we're gonna
make recommendations just for you let's
take a look at connect and see what some
of my favorite artists are up to
so here's Pharrell and some behind the
scenes footage here's Chris Cornell this
is an interesting one he's actually
posted lyrics of a new song that's
coming out before obviously he's even
recorded it it is a revolutionary music
service with recommendations just for
you a worldwide live radio station with
the world's best DJs an exciting way for
fans to connect with artists and of
course this is joined by the iTunes
Music Store the best place to buy music
Apple music will be just $9.99 a month
the cost of an album and we want
everyone to try it and so we're making
the first three months free
now we want to do something really great
for families today you have to buy a
music subscription for each and every
person or you share an account even
though you're not supposed to and now
all of you can't play at the same time
and your playlists and recommendations
get all messed up well with Apple music
for just $14.99 you can have up to six
family members everyone
everyone gets their own account their
own library their own recommendations
it's an incredible value and that is
Apple music thank you